Speaker 1: Failed. Former President Donald Trump
did a rally this weekend in Ohio in support of
vile Republican candidate for the Senate, J.D.
Vance. Now, very often when Trump does these
speeches, we go through the entire speech looking
at little bits and pieces. I'm not going to do
that today. Today, I want to take a different
approach. I'm going to focus in on two specific
rants rants that only a very delusional and
unhinged person would ever deliver. Now, don't be
confused. Trump did all the normal stuff that he
does at these rallies. He claimed he won in 2020.
He says socialists have taken over the Democratic
Party. He says mail in ballots are fraud. He did
all of that. But I want to focus on two areas
that are so absurd that they're almost comical.
I've told you before how Donald Trump
has seemed obsessed with water pressure,
plumbing and toilets, and many of you
think that that's a joke, but he really is.
And he went on one such rant. Now I'm going
to do something that I don't normally do.
I'm going to play the whole toilet rant for
you together just to give you a sense of
how sick this guy is. Stick with it. It's
minutes long, but that's the point here.
This is what he's doing at a rally.
Speaker 4: I said, we're going to do something
about it, and we did that with many industries.
But that one, I went up to the Whirlpool factory
where they make it, and it was incredible.
And that's washers, dryers, all of that stuff,
the dishwashers. And then we changed some rules,
too. You know, I said, What's the problem? Can we
help you? Well, they don't give us any water for
the dishwasher. What does that mean that we don't
have enough water? You know, the ladies, usually
mostly the ladies, in some cases, just to protect.
Speaker 1: As far as Trump knows,
it's usually women washing dishes.
Speaker 4: In some cases, the men OK. He'll say
it was a terrible thing, he said. He said only
the ladies worked out. Now there are some men out
there, too. They're not so happy about it either.
But in the dishwashers, as an example, they
had a little problem. What was the problem?
They didn't give you any water, and it was
so little water that you couldn't wash the
dishes. So what do people do?
Speaker 1: This is an
issue Trump knows a lot about
Speaker 4: being a do it again,
do it again, do it again. So by the time you
do it 10 times, the dishes are finally there.
You've wasted a lot of electricity and you
spend more water than if you did it right.
So I had a regulation where I let you have
all the damn water you want for your dish.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, this is all a lie.
Like, I have one of these, you know, modern
dishwashers that doesn't use a lot of water. I
don't even have to scrape the dishes. I mean,
they just they come out perfectly every time.
Speaker 4: And the same thing for your closing.
Same thing for your clothing, for your dish, for
your dishwashers. Grateful for your washers and
dryers in the washes. They had no water coming
out, and I just asked these simple questions to
the head of Whirlpool. Who the hell knows better
than them? I said, You have a problem. Yeah,
the problem is there's not enough water.
I also did it, by the way, for your sinks,
you ever go to a new home, you buy a nice new
home because of the Trump policies obviously
going up like crazy. By the way, I hate to tell
you, the stock market dropped over 1000 points
Speaker 1: free association of Ideas
all over the place, but he eventually
gets back to his favorite, which is toilets,
Speaker 4: on Friday. Lots of luck, everybody.
But you ever go into a new home and you
turn on the faucet and there's no water
comes out. They have restrictions. And you
know, we're talking about places. You don't
have a water problem. A lot of say most
states don't have a water problem. In fact,
you do have a water problem. You have too much
water. You don't know what to do with it. So. They
have restrictions, so you're sitting there washing
your hands. Come on water, come out baby water.
Speaker 1: Why should I have to tell you if this
guy hadn't been president of the United States,
like in a normal country where
this guy wouldn't be elected?
This would actually be hilarious. Like, this
is hilarious, but they made this guy president.
Speaker 4: I got rid of it. Same thing
with showers. I'd go into a shower
and I'd go to a hotel that was new and I said,
I can't stay in these places. Why the water just
drips out a little bit slowly. I want to take
good care of my hair. I don't want that. No
issue. I mean, I put the soap in. It takes you 20
minutes. Have the water come out to get the damn
soap out of your hair? But and I won't talk about
the third element of a bathroom because every
time I do, the fake news only talks about,
Speaker 1: yeah, he when he when he goes,
his real passion is toilets and
flushing them 10 to 15 times,
but he gets punished when he talks about it.
Speaker 4: But you know what I'm talking about
one time, two times, five times.
Ten times. No water comes out.
Speaker 1: So can anybody in the audience
tell me if you've had to flush the toilet
10 times? I mean, really, you know, in
all honesty, Trump is obsessed with this,
and I don't know what he's flushing. We know
sometimes he flushes secret documents. Maybe
that's why he's flushing 10 times.
Speaker 4: I totally took that out
and we made it so that when you have a sink,
you could actually wash your hands normally
and you can take a shower and
you can do that other thing
normally. The third element of the
bathroom? Oh, so we did it with the
dryers. We did so because this it's insane.
Speaker 1: It's a three minute rant about
plumbing. Then Trump unprovoked, brings
up the dementia test. OK? Starts out of
thin air. There's no rhyme or reason. And
again, we're doing this a little differently.
This is the full dementia rant. And Liz, he's
bragging about it. It's he thinks it's an IQ test.
It's just meant to screen for serious dementia.
Speaker 4: Dr. Ronny and many doctors and I raised
it. And you know, now they don't call me stupid.
They say he's a dictator. He wants to take over
the world. You know, they used to call me J.D..
They may, they said, may be stupid. So I said,
to duck Ronnie, you know, duck Ronnie is
now a great congressman in Texas. Great,
very popular guy. I think he won by like 52
points or something, right? But he's now a
great congressman. I said, Ronnie, I don't like
when people call me stupid. I had great heritage,
an uncle who is a great, great genius, by the way.
Speaker 1: Great heritage. I guess Trump thinks
he's predisposed to be smart because
his uncle was smart as weird heritage.
It's almost like saying he had good blood
Speaker 4: father who is a genius. Everybody
else. We have a lot of geniuses. I don't like
being called stupid. Is there a test or something
I can take to prove to these radical left maniacs?
Speaker 1: Yeah, the test would maybe be an IQ
test, even though that's questionable,
not just the dementia screening
Speaker 4: that are much smarter than
them. Is there a test? And he said,
Sure, there is a test. It's called the X
test. I said, What's it like? He said, Well,
it's gets very tough. The first questions are
easy and middle of the test gets tough, and now
Speaker 1: we all know it doesn't get
tough. We went we've gone through the
test. It's the Montreal cognitive assessment
Speaker 4: that the test is quite tough. So
actually, I said, Well, what happens if
I don't do well? He said, Well, you know,
it's it's at this great hospital, you know,
our great military hospital. We all know our
military hospital and the system is incredible,
incredible doctors. So I said Walter Reed, I said,
Speaker 1: by the way, it's just a piece of paper.
You don't even really need to go to a hospital to
take this test. It's it's a single piece of paper.
Speaker 4: Let me take it. He said, Sir, here's
the problem if you don't do well, everyone's
going to be reading about it at the front pages.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, that's not
true because they would if he didn't
do well, they would just never talk
Speaker 4: about it, they said. And
if I do do well, nobody's going to talk about it.
That's the way it works with the fake news. They
don't talk about it. So I said, he said, and other
people are present while you're taking it, sir.
I said, Let's go. Dr. Ronny, give me that goddamn
test, whether I want to take that course. Give me
that test stock rally. So they gave it to me and
they start asking questions. And some, you know,
around the third or fourth or fifth
question, Sir, sir. Name five things
they didn't. Five things like
Speaker 1:
a group of people. Now Trump here is struggling
to even do it, but he's actually struggling.
Speaker 4: Ohio. A fake teleprompter
that I never end up using.
And the fake news. Thank you so very
much. Thank you. Then they come back
to you 20 minutes later named the five
things you named and I hit it perfectly.
Speaker 1: That's pretty tough. It's like a
hole in one in golf. It's really tough to do.
Speaker 4: They say nobody hits that one. And
when we told that, you know, we told it on
Fox, I hope Fox gets all straightened out.
Speaker 1: All right. I can't. I really can't do
anymore bragging about a dementia test and saying
it makes some really, really smart. So a bizarre
rally. One more clip. There were the normal
glitches here. Is Trump struggling to say Dropbox?
Speaker 4: No more? Dropbox
Dropbox. Is it just so bad? No.
Speaker 1: All right. So listen, this is a
guy who, if he was not president at one point,
would be hilarious. This would be absolutely
hilarious. It would almost be. It would almost be
lovably hilarious. My dementia test and I'm mad
about flushing toilets. He was president and
he was using those toilets to flush secret
documents. And it is absolutely horrifying